The fight for truth
In a dark world, where truth is hard to find.
Good men rise for justice.
They bind.
Amidst the evil eyes, immoral people say
they'll fight for truth
come what may.
With hearts aflame they take a firm stand.
Unyielding, they raise their hand.
They see through veils of
deceit, their mission clear.
They will never retreat in shadows deep.
Where darkness breeds they plant
their seeds of noble deeds.
Without fear they'll lead the blind.
'Cuz walking in faith is the answer for mankind.
They follow the light, they forge ahead.
Their footsteps firm
no falsehood spread.
And all the chaos whispers loud.
They speak the truth, they make it proud.
They want to set the captives free.
Breaking Satan's grip, you see.
For lies may dance and falsehood sway.
But, good men's voices won't betray.
With every word, they break suffocating chains.
Igniting hope, wherever doubt remains.
Their conviction pure, their purpose strong.
They battle with God's armor, all day long.
Through raging storms, they'll navigate.
With righteousness written on their breastplate.
The spirit burns through them,
shining bright, guiding lost
souls to the true light.
So let them rise, these warriors bold.
Their belt of truth, they will uphold.
In a suffering world, where many deceive.
Good men fight, because their hearts believe.
With love and light, their missions clear.
To banish darkness, and conquer fear.
Their hearts ablaze, a fiery might.
They battle demons, day and night.
With the shield of faith, they stand tall.
Defeating evil, one and all.
The battle is souls to save.
For every human life, a chance they crave.
With God's mercy, they heal deep scars.
Transforming lives, like shooting stars.
No longer bound by Satan's hold,
they find their true identity, their Spirits bold.
Through repentance they found release.
And embraced a life of inner peace.
So, let them rise, these warriors brave.
And run the race until you meet the grave.